Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to let's go to
Roy from South Jersey. Roy, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: David. Sir. Yes, please. I was
wondering for your audience if they don't
understand the Marshall Plan. Basically,
after World War two, we funded a lot of the
Western countries that we occupied and turned
them into liberal democracies. I was wondering
what you think about that as a huge international
aid package towards South and Central America. And
I understand that a lot of the times that you get
international funding into countries which aren't
very democratic, they can get embezzled. But and
obviously the Republicans would never go for it.
But what would you think about that in order to
you know, I know a lot of people get mad when they
hear expand freedom and democracy. They think of
the Bush model. But do you think that could work?
Speaker 1: No, I think I mean, OK, in a
hypothetical vacuum, could it work? Maybe.
But U.S. involvement in Central and South America
has been so disastrous over the years that,
first of all, we have no credibility with which
we would put in place a Central and South America
Marshall Plan type equivalent. I think what
we should be doing with regard with Cuba, I've
already laid out we've got to stop the embargo.
And then if we want to help help through U.S. aid
and other organizations do it that way, I would
like to see it handled similarly when it comes to,
you know, when we talk about the undocumented
immigration issue, one of the big factors in
people coming to the US is what are the what are
the circumstances in their source country? So I
think there are ways to improve circumstances
in the countries people are coming from without
doing it as a Marshall Plan, where the idea of
spreading democracy is really code so often for
the United States for horrible interventionist
imperialism. So I want to help the U.S. said
I want to help in that way. But no, I think I'm
not I'm not loving the idea you're proposing.
Speaker 2: All right, one other question,
what is your opinion on couscous?
Speaker 1: I am very much in favor of couscous.
I particularly like that larger grain,
larger size Israeli couscous as I know it. But
really, I am I am in favor of couscous broadly,
narrowly and in most forms, quite frankly.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm glad we could
agree on one thing, at least.
Speaker 1: Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you. OK, thank you very much,
an absolutely perfect phone call.
Speaker 2: Stand back and stand by.
Speaker 1: Why don't we go next? Oh,
actually, no. You know what? I'm being told by
the 300 people on my staff that I have to take
a quick break. OK, so we're going to go to a very,
very quick break. If you're holding to talk to me,
don't hang up and then we'll go right
back to the Dischord Lines momentarily.